[Music]
this right here is what we're going to
build to this video a certain animated
approach to thinking about a super
important idea from math the fourier
transform
for anyone unfamiliar with what that is
my number one goal here is just for the
video to be an introduction to that
topic but even for those of you who are
already familiar with it i still think
that there's something fun and enriching
about seeing what all of its components
actually look like
the central example to start is going to
be the classic one decomposing
frequencies from sound but after that i
also really want to show a glimpse of
how this idea extends well beyond sound
and frequency into many seemingly
disparate areas of math and even physics
really it is crazy just how ubiquitous
this idea is
let's dive in
this sound right here is a pure a 440
beats per second meaning if you were to
measure the air pressure right next to
your headphones or your speaker as a
function of time it would oscillate up
and down around its usual equilibrium in
this wave making 440 oscillations each
second
a lower pitch note like a d has the same
structure just fewer beats per second
and when both of them are played at once
what do you think the resulting pressure
versus time graph looks like
well at any point in time this pressure
difference is going to be the sum of
what it would be for each of those notes
individually
which let's face it is kind of a
complicated thing to think about
at some points the peaks match up with
each other resulting in a really high
pressure
at other points they tend to cancel out
and all in all what you get is a waveish
pressure versus time graph that is not a
pure sine wave it's something more
complicated
and as you add in other notes the wave
gets more and more complicated but right
now all it is is a combination of four
pure frequencies so it seems needlessly
complicated given the low amount of
information put into it
a microphone recording any sound just
picks up on the air pressure at many
different points in time
it only sees the final sum so our
central question is going to be how you
can take a signal like this and
decompose it into the pure frequencies
that make it up
pretty interesting right adding up those
signals really mixes them all together
so pulling them back apart feels akin to
unmixing multiple paint colors that have
all been stirred up together
the general strategy is going to be to
build for ourselves a mathematical
machine that treats signals with a given
frequency
differently from how it treats other
signals
to start consider simply taking a pure
signal say with a lowly three beats per
second so that we can plot it easily and
let's limit ourselves to looking at a
finite portion of this graph in this
case the portion between 0 seconds and
4.5 seconds
the key idea is going to be to take this
graph and sort of wrap it up around a
circle
concretely here's what i mean by that
imagine a little rotating vector where
at each point in time its length is
equal to the height of our graph for
that time so high points of the graph
correspond to a greater distance from
the origin
and low points end up closer to the
origin
and right now i'm drawing it in such a
way that moving forward two seconds in
time corresponds to a single rotation
around the circle
our little vector drawing this wound up
graph is rotating at half a cycle per
second
so this is important there are two
different frequencies at play here
there's the frequency of our signal
which goes up and down three times per
second and then separately there's the
frequency with which we're wrapping the
graph around the circle which at the
moment is half of a rotation per second
but we can adjust that second frequency
however we want maybe we want to wrap it
around faster
or maybe we go and wrap it around slower
and that choice of winding frequency
determines what the wound up graph looks
like
some of the diagrams that come out of
this can be pretty complicated although
they are very pretty but it's important
to keep in mind that all that's
happening here is that we're wrapping
the signal around a circle
the vertical lines that i'm drawing up
top by the way are just a way to keep
track of the distance on the original
graph that corresponds to a full
rotation around the circle
so lines spaced out by 1.5 seconds would
mean it takes 1.5 seconds to make one
full revolution
and at this point we might have some
sort of vague sense that something
special will happen when the winding
frequency matches the frequency of our
signal 3 beats per second
all of the high points on the graph
happen on the right side of the circle
and all of the low points happen on the
left
but how precisely can we take advantage
of that in our attempt to build a
frequency unmixing machine
well imagine this graph is having some
kind of mass to it like a metal wire
this little dot is going to represent
the center of mass of that wire
as we change the frequency and the graph
winds up differently that center of mass
kind of wobbles around a bit
and for most of the winding frequencies
the peaks and the valleys are all spaced
out around the circle in such a way that
the center of mass stays pretty close to
the origin
[Music]
but
when the winding frequency is the same
as the frequency of our signal in this
case three cycles per second all of the
peaks are on the right and all of the
valleys are on the left so the center of
mass is unusually far to the right
here to capture this let's draw some
kind of plot that keeps track of where
that center of mass is for each winding
frequency
of course the center of mass is a two
dimensional thing it requires two
coordinates to fully keep track of but
for the moment let's only keep track of
the x-coordinate
so for a frequency of zero when
everything is bunched up on the right
this x-coordinate is relatively high
and then as you increase that winding
frequency
and the graph balances out around the
circle
the x-coordinate of that center of mass
goes closer to zero and it just kind of
wobbles around a bit
[Music]
but then at three beats per second
there's a spike as everything lines up
to the right
this right here is the central construct
so let's sum up what we have so far we
have that original intensity versus time
graph
and then we have the wound up version of
that in some two-dimensional plane
and then as a third thing we have a plot
for how the winding frequency influences
the center of mass of that graph
and by the way let's look back at those
really low frequencies near zero
this big spike around zero in our new
frequency plot just corresponds to the
fact that the whole cosine wave is
shifted up
if i had chosen a signal that oscillates
around zero dipping into negative values
then as we play around with various
winding frequencies this plot of the
winding frequency versus center of mass
would only have a spike at the value of
three
but negative values are a little bit
weird and messy to think about
especially for our first example so
let's just continue thinking in terms of
the shifted up graph
i just want you to understand that that
spike around zero only corresponds to
the shift our main focus as far as
frequency decomposition is concerned is
that bump at three
this whole plot is what i'll call the
almost fourier transform of the original
signal there's a couple small
distinctions between this and the actual
fourier transform which i'll get to in a
couple minutes but already you might be
able to see how this machine lets us
pick out the frequency of a signal
just to play around with it a little bit
more take a different pure signal let's
say with a lower frequency of two beats
per second and do the same thing
wind it around a circle
imagine different potential winding
frequencies and as you do that keep
track of where the center of mass of
that graph is
and then plot the x coordinate of that
center of mass as you adjust the winding
frequency
just like before we get a spike when the
winding frequency is the same as the
signal frequency which in this case is
when it equals two cycles per second
but the real key point the thing that
makes this machine so delightful is how
it enables us to take a signal
consisting of multiple frequencies and
pick out what they are
imagine taking the two signals we just
looked at the wave with three beats per
second and the wave with two beats per
second and add them up
like i said earlier what you get is no
longer a nice pure cosine wave it's
something a little more complicated but
imagine throwing this into our winding
frequency machine
it is certainly the case that as you
wrap this thing around it looks a lot
more complicated to have this chaos and
chaos and chaos and chaos and then whoop
things seem to line up really nicely at
two cycles per second then as you
continue on it's more chaos and more
chaos more chaos chaos gas gas whoop
things nicely align again at three
cycles per second and like i said before
the wound up graph can look kind of busy
and complicated but all it is is the
relatively simple idea of wrapping the
graph around a circle it's just a more
complicated graph and a pretty quick
winding frequency now what's going on
here with the two different spikes is
that if you were to take two signals and
then apply this almost fourier transform
to each of them individually and then
add up the results what you get is the
same as if you first added up the
signals and then applied this almost
fourier transform
and the attentive viewers among you
might want to pause and ponder and
convince yourself that what i just said
is actually true it's a pretty good test
to verify for yourself that it's clear
what exactly is being measured inside
this winding machine
now this property makes things really
useful to us because the transform of a
pure frequency is close to zero
everywhere except for a spike around
that frequency
so when you add together two pure
frequencies the transform graph just has
these little peaks above the frequencies
that went into it
so this little mathematical machine does
exactly what we wanted it pulls out the
original frequencies from their jumbled
up sums unmixing the mixed bucket of
paint
and before continuing into the full math
that describes this operation let's just
get a quick glimpse of one context where
this thing is useful sound editing let's
say that you have some recording and
it's got an annoying high pitch that you
would like to filter out
well at first your signal is coming in
as a function of various intensities
over time different voltages given to
your speaker from one millisecond to the
next but we want to think of this in
terms of frequencies
so
when you take the fourier transform of
that signal the annoying high pitched is
going to show up just as a spike at some
high frequency
filtering that out by just smushing the
spike down what you'd be looking at is
the fourier transform of a sound that's
just like you're recording only without
that high frequency
luckily there's a notion of an inverse
fourier transform that tells you which
signal would have produced this as its
fourier transform i'll be talking about
that in first much more fully in the
next video but long story short applying
the fourier transform to the fourier
transform gives you back something close
to the original function
kind of this is a little bit of a lie
but it's in the direction of truth and
most of the reason that it's a lie is
that i still have yet to tell you what
the actual fourier transform is since
it's a little more complex than this x
coordinate of the center of mass idea
first off bringing back this wound up
graph and looking at its center of mass
the x coordinate is really only half the
story right i mean this thing is in two
dimensions it's got a y coordinate as
well and as is typical in math whenever
you're dealing with something two
two-dimensional it's elegant to think of
it as the complex plane where this
center of mass is going to be a complex
number that has both a real and an
imaginary part
and the reason for talking in terms of
complex numbers rather than just saying
it has two coordinates is that complex
numbers lend themselves to really nice
descriptions of things that have to do
with winding and rotation
for example euler's formula famously
tells us that if you take e to some
number times i you're going to land on
the point that you get if you were to
walk that number of units around a
circle with radius 1 counterclockwise
starting on the right
so
imagine you wanted to describe rotating
at a rate of one cycle per second
one thing that you could do is take the
expression e to the two pi times i times
t where t is the amount of time that has
passed since for a circle with radius
one 2 pi describes the full length of
its circumference
and this is a little bit dizzying to
look at so maybe you want to describe a
different frequency something lower and
more reasonable and for that you would
just multiply that time t in the
exponent by the frequency f
for example if f was 1 10 then this
vector makes one full turn every 10
seconds since the time t has to increase
all the way to 10 before the full
exponent looks like 2 pi i i have
another video giving some intuition on
why this is the behavior of e to the x
for imaginary inputs if you're curious
but for right now we're just going to
take it as a given
now why am i telling you this you might
ask well it gives us a really nice way
to write down the idea of winding up the
graph into a single tight little formula
first off the convention in the context
of fourier transforms is to think about
rotating in the clockwise direction so
let's go ahead and throw a negative sign
up into that exponent
now take some function describing a
signal intensity versus time like this
pure cosine wave we had before and call
it g of t
if you multiply this exponential
expression times g of t
it means that the rotating complex
number is getting scaled up and down
according to the value of this function
so you can think of this little rotating
vector with its changing length as
drawing the wound up graph
so think about it this is awesome this
really small expression is a super
elegant way to encapsulate the whole
idea of winding a graph around a circle
with a variable frequency f
and remember the thing we want to do
with this wound up graph is to track its
center of mass so think about what
formula is going to capture that
well to approximate it at least you
might sample a whole bunch of times from
the original signal
see where those points end up on the
wound up graph and then just take an
average that is add them all together as
complex numbers and then divide by the
number of points that you've sampled
this will become more accurate if you
sample more points which are closer
together
and in the limit rather than looking at
the sum of a whole bunch of points
divided by the number of points you take
an integral of this function divided by
the size of the time interval that we're
looking at now the idea of integrating a
complex valued function might seem weird
and to anyone who's shaky with calculus
may be even intimidating but the
underlying meaning here really doesn't
require any calculus knowledge the whole
expression is just the center of mass of
the wound up graph
so great step by step we have built up
this kind of complicated but let's face
it surprisingly small expression for the
whole winding machine idea that i talked
about and now there is only one final
distinction to point out between this
and the actual honest-to-goodness
fourier transform
namely just don't divide out by the time
interval the fourier transform is just
the integral part of this
what that means is that instead of
looking at the center of mass you would
scale it up by some amount
if the portion of the original graph you
were using spanned three seconds you
would multiply the center of mass by
three
if it was spanning six seconds you would
multiply the center of mass by 6.
physically this has the effect that when
a certain frequency persists for a long
time then the magnitude of the fourier
transform at that frequency is scaled up
more and more for example what we're
looking at right here is how when you
have a pure frequency of two beats per
second and you wind it around the graph
at two cycles per second
the center of mass stays in the same
spot right it's just tracing out the
same shape but the longer that signal
persists the larger the value of the
fourier transform at that frequency for
other frequencies though even if you
just increase it by a bit this is
canceled out by the fact that for longer
time intervals you're giving the wound
up graph more of a chance to balance
itself around the circle
that is a lot of different moving parts
so let's step back and summarize what we
have so far
the fourier transform of an intensity
versus time function like gft is a new
function which doesn't have time as an
input but instead takes in a frequency
what i've been calling the winding
frequency
in terms of notation by the way the
common convention is to call this new
function g hat with a little circumflex
on top of it
now the output of this function is a
complex number some point in the 2d
plane that corresponds to the strength
of a given frequency in the original
signal
the plot that i've been graphing for the
fourier transform is just the real
component of that output the x
coordinate but you could also graph the
imaginary component separately if you
wanted a fuller description
and all of this is encapsulated inside
that formula that we built up and out of
context you can imagine how seeing this
formula would seem sort of daunting but
if you understand how exponentials
correspond to rotation
how multiplying that by the function g
of t means drawing a wound up version of
the graph
and how an integral of a complex valued
function can be interpreted in terms of
a center of mass idea
you can see how this whole thing carries
with it a very rich intuitive meaning
and by the way one quick small note
before we can call this wrapped up even
though in practice with things like
sound editing you'll be integrating over
a finite time interval the theory of
fourier transforms is often phrased
where the bounds of this integral are
negative infinity and infinity
concretely what that means is that you
consider this expression for all
possible finite time intervals and you
just ask what is its limit as that time
interval grows to infinity
and man oh man there is so much more to
say so much i don't want to call it done
here this transform extends the corners
of math well beyond the idea of
extracting frequencies from signal
so the next video i put out is going to
go through a couple of these and that's
really where things start getting
interesting
so stay subscribed for when that comes
out or an alternate option is to just
binge on a couple three blue on brown
videos so that the youtube recommender
is more inclined to show you new things
that come out really the choice is yours
and to close things off i have something
pretty fun a mathematical puzzler from
this video sponsor jane street who's
looking to recruit more technical talent
so let's say that you have a closed
bounded convex set c sitting in 3d space
and then let b be the boundary of that
space the surface of your complex blob
now imagine taking every possible pair
of points on that surface and adding
them up doing a vector sum
let's name this set of all possible sums
d your task is to prove that d is also a
convex set
so jane street is a quantitative trading
firm and if you're the kind of person
who enjoys math and solving puzzles like
this the team there really values
intellectual curiosity so they might be
interested in hiring you and they're
looking both for full-time employees and
interns for my part i can say the couple
of people i've interacted with there
just seem to love math and sharing math
and when they're hiring they look less
at a background in finance than they do
at how you think how you learn and how
you solve problems hence the sponsorship
of a three blue one brown video
if you want the answer to that puzzler
or to learn more about what they do or
to apply for open positions go to
janestreet.com
3b1b
[Music]
[Music]
you